[Music]
Wow what is that thing this is just
McDonald's standing in for reviewer
James Akana StarLink battle for Atlas is
a game about flying through space
exploring new planets and shooting a lot
of aliens sat in a seamless open world
galaxy it sees you pushing back
occupying forces by battling enemies
setting up outposts and completing
simple tasks set by your allies for
better and worse it's a distinctly
Ubisoft game from the huge spaces to the
maps overloaded with activities but
thankfully StarLink is not quite so full
that it feels bloated just full enough
that there's always something for you to
be working towards StarLink is also
Ubisoft's entry into the toys to life
market you're able to buy physical packs
of pilots weapons and ships all of which
are interchangeable and have their own
unique attributes and abilities
constructing and attaching these models
to your controller using a specialized
mounting device will give you access to
those characters and tools in game and
while swapping between all these
components isn't necessary doing so
brings distinct advantages
the Akamai starlings combat is fun
thanks to simple controls and the two
weapons system different enemies are
weak against or impervious to different
weapon types and swapping the two
weapons mounted on your ship will change
your methods of attack and the kinds of
Elemental combos you can perform every
weapon can be leveled up individually
and augmented with mods that you collect
so by the end of the game your most used
guns will likely be able to absolutely
rip through certain enemies provided you
have the foresight to equip them
which applies now I will be toast
malaria
when your grounded on a planet you'll be
doing a lot of strafing and aiming for
big glowing weak points whereas fights
in space are more freewheeling with dog
fights often pitting you against swarms
of enemy fighters these feel like all
range mode battles from starfox and
swinging around to land a precision
assault on an enemy is satisfying every
time like weapons each pilot has their
own upgrade tree and unique special
ability and they even get their own
unique script during missions which is a
great touch there are only a few big
story driven missions and in the back
half of the game you're given some
freedom as to how you go about weakening
the enemy forces there's an order of
operations in each sector of space
clairaut
mining sites guarded by enemies to
weaken Prime's which are big robot
monsters on each planet killing Prime's
on planets that are near each other will
weaken a related dreadnought a giant
spaceship that will in turn produce more
Prime's if you don't take it out - the
one drawback to this structure though is
that you're essentially taking on the
same kinds of fights with occasional
difficulty spikes taking out the game's
three dreadnaughts will make the final
boss easier and you can theoretically
take on a dreadnought at its maximum
strength regardless of how underleveled
you are it's repetitive but you also get
a good sense of your progression and the
feedback loop of loot and rewards hits a
good balance where you rarely feel like
you're stuck grinding the battles might
repeat a lot - but they're consistently
entertaining and figuring out the best
way to take down a huge enemy with the
tools you have on hand is a satisfying
challenge the dreadnaughts are
particularly fun to take down everytime
you take out one of their mounted guns a
swarm of enemy ships will attack leading
to the game's most intense dogfighting
and each encounter ends with a Star Wars
inspired fly into the center and destroy
the core sequence
if you're playing on Nintendo's switch
you'll have access to fox mccloud
and his arwing he can call in one of the
other members of staff Fox complete with
the corneria theme from the original
game and if you're a fan it's very
tempting to place him the entire game
the switch version consistently runs
smoothly though there's a visual
trade-off the planets are not
particularly detailed everything's a
little fuzzier in handheld mode and
there's a lot of poppin it's weird to
have an asteroid belt suddenly appear in
front of you when you're flying towards
a planet but the South Fox phone service
throughout the game is a great bonus
especially in the mini five mission
campaign in which the team hunts down
longtime antagonist wolf O'Donnell
[Music]
wolf is a much more interesting enemy
than Andres as it turns out and while
this campaign is short it feels true to
the spirit of the series Fox and his
team get integrated into the rest of the
game - popping up in cutscenes with the
rest of the StarLink crew
unfortunately the games primary plot
which concerns a crew of adventurers
trying to save their captured captain
and take down the Forgotten Legion
forces led by an alien named Grox
is much less exciting strangely despite
battle for Atlas being the first and
only existing game in the StarLink
series the script feels as though it's
written for players who have a
pre-existing relationship with these
characters and their situation meaning
there's not much in the way of paid loss
or catharsis to be found some of the
characters are interesting but even
though the game is keen to throw law at
you this little sense of who these
characters are what sort of universe
they exist in or even what their
fundamental role is beyond needing to
take down this enemy force this is the
only Intel I trust the legions got a
hierarchy and orders got to come from
somewhere let's crack a few more open
and see where that gets us that's not
very diplomatic but it could work
what are we waiting for let's get out
there despite this it's always clear
what your overarching objectives are and
how you need to work towards them
there's a lot that you can be doing at
any given point even in the vastness of
outer space there are racks to salvage
gear from and enemy outposts to take
down Rex can be identified from there
flashing beacons and usually contain
loot while outposts are added to your
map as you chase outlaws from planets
exploring the depths of space reveals
plenty of neat loot and fun encounters
and the thrill of taking off from one
planet seamlessly flying into space and
landing on another never gets old
but starlings proposition as a choice to
life product is hampered somewhat by the
comparative financial value of the
digital alternative the physical starter
pack varies in content between consoles
but they each give you far less than
both the starter and deluxe digital
versions which unlock multiple ships
pilots and weapons from the get-go if
you get the physical starter pack and
don't want to buy additional toys you
can still finish the game but you'll be
at an enormous disadvantage having
multiple ships in Starling essentially
operates as having extra lives if you
get wrecked during a battle you can
choose to either quit or replace the
ship immediately if you don't have a
replacement certain battles are going to
be a real struggle and progress doesn't
carry over when you come back to them
it's easy to lose a ship - especially
since your defensive options during
fights are often limited you can summon
a shield or barrel roll but both eat
into your limited energy supply which
takes a while to recharge the digital
starter pack gives you four ships five
on switch which feels fairer and lets
you worry less during big battles
between ships and weapons pilots are
less vital you'd have to buy quite a few
toys if you wanted a varied and balanced
experience the ship models themselves
look great though and while switching
loadouts via the menus is always going
to be the more convenient option
physically swapping out the components
will pause the game until your ship is
completely decked out again
well whose idea was this anyway
changing pilots will require you to
remove the entire ship first
but that's only a minor pain the only
real impediment is being able to
remember which weapon does walk by sight
but their designs are distinctive enough
that this isn't an issue once you get
accustomed to them
StarLink is an interesting and enjoyable
open-world game one that fully
understands the appeal of exploring new
planets and dogfighting in the cold
depths of space with a small fleet of
ships at your disposal it can be a lot
of fun to progressively assault and
weaken the forgotten legions hold on the
galaxy it's just a shame that if you're
interested in the physical models you'll
have to spend more to get the same
experience as the digital version
[Music]
pirate ship online all systems on
reserve power
[Music]